[Music]
this morning as part of our ideas that
matter series with ted we're taking a
closer look at the way many of us were
feeling during the pandemic
organizational psychologist adam grant
noticed his behavior was changing as the
months were on now he wasn't actually
depressed just feeling a little bit
aimless and joyless so like any good
scientist he did some research and
figured out what was bothering him adam
grant joins us right now good morning
adam how are you doing yay
morning nate go lions
go lions that's what i'm talking about
all right now you're helping us become
lions in our own life but i want to
focus on a word that you brought up
quite a bit and that's languishing um a
sense of emptiness and stagnation you
know what's the difference between
languishing and feeling
um depressed
so i think the basic difference is when
you're depressed you feel hopeless
whereas when you're languishing you just
sort of feel meh or blah
it's not necessarily the presence of
mental illness it's just the absence of
peak mental health it's the sociologist
cory keys to find it and i think so many
of us have gone through this during the
pandemic right we've we've kind of felt
like we're in pandemic fog like we're
having trouble concentrating and it's
just feeling a little bit aimless and a
little bit jointless
yeah could we be languishing adam and
we're not even aware of it because you
said we really need to rethink what it
means rethink our mental health and
well-being what do you mean by that yeah
well gail i think languishing might be
the neglected middle child of mental
health and it's entirely possible that
you're languishing right now and you
didn't even notice because it's just
sort of uh
yeah on your ted talk adam you give a
great example i go i've done that where
you're binge watching on bad tv thinking
why am i even doing this what is wrong
with me
but nobody wants to go through life or
blah
no have i seen this show before i don't
even remember
i think i think the challenge for so
many of us is that the world around us
has been stagnating right in the early
days of the pandemic it was acute
anguish now it's much more chronic
language and every time we have a new
variant it seems like we're going
through the motions all over again
it's hard to have something to look
forward to when you don't know where
forward is
all right so adam we know now what
languishing is and whether you've got it
how do you beat it
well i don't know that it's always easy
but i think the first thing i would do
is i would shift your attention away
from the external circumstances and
toward your inner emotions right a lot
of people are saying well i've never
been through a pandemic before i'm not
really sure what to do and it is true
unless you're 102 years old you probably
have not lived through a pandemic and
even then i'm guessing you wouldn't
remember it very well
if you focus instead on on the internal
state that you're experiencing you know
what we have all languished before i
think most people had a whole semester
of languishing in college and if you you
think about those emotions and how you
felt them in the past sometimes you can
learn lessons from your own resilience
what was it that got you through
languishing last time and how can you
apply that today
so for you uh it was video games one in
particular super mario kart oh yeah a
lot of teenagers in the room right now
whose ears just perked up and there's a
lot of 40 year olds yeah a lot of 40
people
yeah four-year-olds can do what they
want
mom and dad might say hey less video
games so why why did video games work
for you what was the key
well this 40 year old benefited a lot
from them last year
my three kids were home in online school
and it was just hard to give them
anything to look forward to and we
started playing mario kart online with
my sister and brother-in-law and all of
a sudden after a couple weeks i i felt
like i was languishing yet less and i
think some of it was the mastery right
there's nothing like the sweet
satisfaction of of aiming a green shell
for your brother-in-law to get hit by um
some of it was the mindfulness i had to
focus completely otherwise i would lose
um but most importantly i felt like i
could do something that mattered right i
was able to give my kids something to
look forward to when there wasn't really
a lot to do
adam i have to say for anybody who
hasn't seen your ted talk run don't walk
to see it it's 16 minutes of your time
well spent you talk about toxic
positivity we don't have time for that i
want to end with this
so we're not feeling blah and mad how do
you want us to emerge from these
challenging times how can we emerge
well i don't know that there's
necessarily an easy answer but i think
one thing we've learned in psychology is
that instead of seeking advice from
other people it's sometimes more helpful
to give it so i would say find somebody
who's languishing give them some
suggestions and the advice you give is
probably the advice you needed to take
i like that yeah that's good bad
adam grant you never disappoint thank
you so much really good to see you this
morning